tuesday 6 30 eastern on cbs
we are three days away from election day
but this year some cities have seen a
surge in early voting
helping to get voters motivated and to
the polls is a team of unconventional
people
that describes themselves as artistic
activists
they're part of the unstoppable voters
project the project is
an 11-part series spread across the
nation that informs voters by bringing
the arts
to the ballot box
[Music]
dancing mailboxes aren't just for show
they're part of a national get out the
vote campaign
using forms of art in black and brown
communities they can be targets of voter
suppression
steve lambert is the founder of the
unstoppable voters project through the
center of artistic
activism a left-leaning nonprofit
pushing
for social change we've worked in
democracies all over the world and when
we had the opportunity to work here in
the united states on this election we
jumped at the chance
there are 11 different initiatives under
this project what's what was your
criteria
or what was the criteria for choosing
them so the criteria
was reach we didn't want art that
regular people wouldn't get you know
which is why we have
circus performers and black cowboy
groups but also that it would
give them valuable information that
would lead to them voting the
initiatives are spread across
15 different states including georgia
hey you georgia yeah you
you got to make a plan to vote a state
historically known for
understaffed polling places and voter
purges
in north carolina there is a
gerrymandering class that allows
participants to create
mock congressional district maps
educating folks on how the tactics can
affect
their representation there seems to be a
strategy
in the methodology so a key part of
these projects
is they don't talk about the problem
they tell you how to solve it and they
address the problem they change the
problem in real life
maya penn the co-director of cirque de
vote
used the same method when she led a
parade to the polls in north
philadelphia last weekend
i looked at the list of early voting
sites
and i picked the leo chorus center
the neighborhood that we paraded through
has a history of like lower
voter turnout once again due to
circumstances that are
so often beyond the voters control
penn believes bringing joy to the polls
will change the narrative of voting
celebrating the act of voting as opposed
to chastising those
who have yet to decide so you're saying
vote shaming
does no one any good i don't feel that
it works
at this moment in time there's like a
there's a lot of outrage
on the street but it is so impactful
it's so impactful to have someone come
to your
neighborhood with a big brass band and
with clowns and say
we're throwing you a party thank you so
much for
sticking through this time thank you for
your resilience let's go vote together
we see you here's the information i'm
here for you
because there are real barriers to
voting i mean you look at places like in
houston texas and harris county where
you have like
one polling uh one drop-off box
you you think you know folks have to get
on a bus some don't have cars
this is a way to get people activated
and motivated to kind of get out there
and